my favorite song you do is this one so
we gonna smoke a house today from the
Same album yeah
unbelievable Gin and Juice I think this
is
an incredible song
[Music]
everybody got their cups but they ain't
chipped in now these types of [__]
happens all the time you gotta get yours
for me I gotta get mine everything is
fine when you're listening to the D.O.G
I got the cultivating musics that be
captivating hate who listens to the
words that I speak as I take me a drink
till the middle Water Street and get
them back into this [__] named Sadies
she used to be my homeboys late it was
80 degrees when I tell that [__] please
raise up all this and you tease cause
you guess none of these at ease those
words are ingrained you perform that
song a lot you know maybe two times in
my life
but that is some song and who makes
songs about Gin and Juice you know what
I mean that's that's inspired anything
come to mind like where did you come up
with that whole concept that's what the
[__] we was drinking every day I swear
to God Dre would come in with a gallon
you know like you have a gallon of milk
yeah he will pour that [__] gallon of
milk out fill it up with orange juice
then he would pour the orange juice
halfway out then he put the rest for gin
and shake that [__] up and we
just be fasten it around like [__] it
and you said I love this gin and juice
so much I am going to make a love song
to Gin and Juice [__] it
good